alors allez comment elle est très bien
aller non les magnifiques elle est bien
été vécue certainement pour beaucoup de
gens c'est un mec qui croise son pote
dans la rue et ils aident le mac à 12
points de suture sur le front quand sa
douce musique ici tu es arrivé vadis et
ma femme dit quoi ta femme
baduel m'a foutu un coup de gigot
d'agneau congelés en pleine gueule dit
pourquoi le fait ça vingt dix pages elle
se baissent c'est beau aller chercher le
gigot dans le congélateur elle ou
l'apport sms elle avait sa petite fille
je push pris cette fois comme j'adore
j'arrive derrière elle je retrousse un
petit peu ça juges écartent le le string
je commence à le prendre que ça le midi
et celle de décalage gros porc qu'est ce
que tu sais quoi
d'habitude à l'indoor synthois hélas la
table gigan 1 me fous la gueule j mais
pourquoi le fait savez ce que tu dis que
d'habitude elles adorent ça eh ben dis
je sais pas peut-être mais ce qu'on
était à auchan
[Applaudissements]